greece's work program for the first six
months of the years on the agenda as eu
economics and finance ministers meet in
brussels for the first time in 2014.
the presidency wants to finalize key
parts of the banking union ahead of the
european elections while working to
restore growth employment and confidence
in the financial sector the european
elections in in may mean that for
particularly for the ecofin council our
program is front loaded that means we
have a limited time of two and a half
almost three months to try to get
through as much of the legislative acts
as possible with parliament top of the
priority list will be negotiations on
the single resolution mechanism which
would help out any european bank or
credit institution in trouble and avoid
financial shocks
those talks involving the european
parliament will move in parallel with
the intergovernmental process on a
single resolution fund a pool of
national resolution funds that could be
used to recapitalize a bank
during the council european central bank
officials will brief ministers on the
state of play concerning the ecb's role
which is to supervise the sector
ensuring that banks have sound finances
and respect the rules
the ministers are also likely to note
the excessive government deficit in the
newest eu member state croatia and
recommend that it be brought back into
line as quickly as possible